I was uh playing the dentist and Jerry
thought I was molesting him in the chair
do you remember that episode and we
rehearse this scene and they all go to
another scene I stayed on that set to
get used to the stool and the
instruments and I Heard a Voice say you
know what would be funny yeah and I look
around and up on a ladder was a guy
adjusting a light I go you talking to me
yeah I went what he goes it'd be funny
if before you gave it to Jerry you took
a hit yourself first oh my God that's
hilarious yes so I waited until we were
shooting and I go nurse may have the
nitrous oxide and I take it and I
go that's good you know and I give it
Jerry Falls over laughing it was
hilarious and Larry David he said Jerry
stop laughing Jerry stop it stop it
let's do it again but then they were
telling me hey great joke and I go
where's the guy and I said that guy gave
it to me and he just did one of these so
it doesn't matter where a good idea
comes from just take it best idea wins